all EU states have signed the trade deal  with Canada but it still needs to pass  the European Parliament screen light the  committee on international trade will  vote on capito three-quarters of all  packaging should be recycled by 2030  that's one among many benchmarks mep on  the Environmental Committee will set to  tackle Europe garbage until now  governments have made their own  decisions about asylum seekers but the  EU is working on an agreed list of place  countries of origin mep s will discuss  the situation on the ground how to  tackle the root causes of migration the  development committee will vote on  coordinating efforts more effectively  [Music]